[Müzik]
Evet herhalde Günün Son oturumunun
cinsellik olmasında Bir Anlamı Olmalı
Çünkü her şey cinsellikle ve zevkle
bitmeli değil mi sevgili kadınlar
O yüzden beni son oturuma yazmışlar
şimdi Dünya nüfusunun dünyadaki
insanların ortalama yarısı biyolojik
olarak kadındır ve onları cinsel hazza
götürecek bir organına sahiptir adı
klitoris yeni tanışmış olabilirsiniz ya
da bir kısmınız bir şekilde bir
yerlerden biliyorsunuz ama ve kadınlar
Eğer bireysel cinsellik yaşıyorlarsa ki
bunun adı mastürbasyon korkmadan
söyleyelim hepsi %90'ı %95'i orgazm
oluyorlar yani mastürbasyon yapıyorlarsa
kadınlar %90-95 orgazm oluyorlar öte
yandan kadınların yüzde ona hayatı
boyunca bununla hiç tanışmamış
Salonu yüzde sekseni kadın böyle bir
orantı yapalım aramızda bazı problemler
var demek ki bununla ilgili Bunlar
hiçbiri benim sayılarım benim kafadan
uydurduğum sayılar değil dünya verileri
Avrupa verileri Türkiye'deki verilerin
nasıl olduğunu hiç bilmiyordum
kadınların %50'si
Buralar minik minik önemli sayılar Çünkü
konumuzun önemi burada
popülasyonun diğer yarısına bakalım
erkekler sevgili Erkekler İster cinsel
eyleminizi bireysel olarak yaşayın adı
mastürbasyon yine korkmadan söylüyoruz
isterse Heteroseksüel bir birliktelik
homoseksüel de olabilir
%90-95 oranında orgazm oluyorsunuz
%5 orgazm olamayan erkeğe karşılık
Heteroseksüel ilişkilerde
%50 kadın orgazm olamıyor
bir yerde bir sorun var Yani bu
rakamlarda bir sorun var şimdi biz Eğer
mastürbasyon esnasında yani bireysel
cinselliğimiz de kendimizi uyarmayı
öğrendiğimizde orgazmı keşfedebiliyorsak
heter sektör İlişkilerde bir sorun mu
var bizim bedenimizde bir sorun yok biz
kendimiz bunu başarabiliyoruz ama demek
ki yaşadığımız ilişkide bir sorun var
Ben kadın doğum uzmanıyım 17 yıldır
asistan'ımla birlikte kadınlarla
çalışıyorum şimdi cinsellik öyle bir
konu ki böyle bazılarımızı rahatsız bile
etti Çünkü bizim gibi topraklarda bu
konu bir tabu
Ama birçok toprakta böyle yani sadece
Türkiye'ye özgü bir şey değil birçok
toprakta böyle
konuşmaya korkuyoruz Ya bırakın Hani
öğrenmeyi falan konuşmaya korkuyoruz
bedenimizde bir organ taşıyoruz
haberimiz yok ondan
öte yandan sevgili erkekler 3 yaşından
beri bir şekilde cinsel organları olan
penise münasebet halindeler çiş yaparken
görüyorlar işte aynaya bakıyorlar
görüyorlar bir şekilde dokunuyorlar
filan zaten onların dokunmasında bir
problem yok göster amcana pipiden pipini
gelen mevzulardan ötürü biz bakıyoruz
Şimdi aynaya bakıyorum yüzümü görüyorum
yüzüm burnum filan genital bölgeme
bakacağım zaten yasak yani bakamayız
baksak bir şey göremiyoruz Bir de İşin
kötüsü böyle bir biyolojik minnacık bir
dezavantajımız var bakınca bir şey
göremiyoruz
Birazcık böyle şey başlıyor sele ki
bizim gibi topraklarda ayıp yasak günah
namus bekaret kavramlarıyla yan yana
gelmiş kadın cinselliğine öğrenemiyoruz
bir şey yani değil mi yani varoluş
sebeplerimizden biri şurada Her biriniz
bugün Buradaysanız cinsellik ürünüsünüz
Bunu kabul edin ama hiçbir şekilde
öğrenemiyoruz
şimdi cinsellik Yine öyle bir konu ki
konuşmaya korkuyoruz öğrenmeye
çekiniyoruz arkadaş arasında konuşurken
çok iyi biliyoruz özellikle erkeklerde
bu böyle
öte yandan merak ediyoruz öğrenmeye
çalışıyoruz cevapları bulamıyoruz çünkü
cevapları arayacak olsak işte internet
falan bilgi kirliliği
erkek penceresinden baktığımızda güç
İktidar Savaşları var
performans kaygıları var değil mi erkek
cinselliğinin de sorunları var kendi
içinde Konumuz o değil ayrıntılı
Konuşmayacağım ama kadın cinselliği
tamamen namus bekar et kavramları ile
ezilmiş bir cinsellik
öte yandan
romantik partnerlerimizle kaynaştığımız
bir şey cinsellik kavgalarımızı
yatıştırdığımız bir şey Cinsellik
nörobiyolojik olarak kanıtlanmış haliyle
bize iyi gelen bir şey cinsellik ama biz
korkuyoruz öğrenmeye korkuyoruz
konuşmaya korkuyoruz Birileri bir şeyler
konuşursa utanıyoruz ama filan ama bir
taraftan da çok meraklıyız değil mi Yani
bu böyle bir iki yüzlülüğümüz var
Özellikle kadın cinselliği konusunda
her şey aslında cinsel
eğitimsizliğimizin suçu hiçbirinizin
suçu değil bizim Eğitim sistemimizin
suçu dünyada çok az ülkede cinsel eğitim
var aranızda cinsel eğitim alan var mı
3 4 2 kaç kişiyiz salonda bilmiyorum
herhalde binde bir oranında bir cinsel
eğitim var Evet ortaokul düzeyinde bazı
ülkelerde Bizim de ülkemizde oluyor bu
bir Sözde bir eğitim veriliyor üreme
odaklı bir cinsel eğitim
birileri geliyor bize bir şeyler
anlatıyor gene üreme organlarımızı
anlatıyor adet olacağımızı anlatıyor
adetlerimiz ağrılı geçebilir Aman diyor
pet filan dağıtıyorlar değil mi böyle
bir cinsel eğitimimiz var önlerde
birileri merakla dinliyor çoğunluk
arkada kıkırdıyor Kimin ne anlattığı
belli değil Konuya vakıf değil Çünkü
anlatan kişi
hiç kimse o salondan Yetiş o sınıftan
yetişkin hayatında ne yaşayacağını
bilerek çıkmıyor
çıkan varsa çok şanslı elini kaldıranlar
çok şanslı
ama biliyor musunuz
Keşke bize üreme organlarımızın yerine
cinsel organlarımızı anlatılsaydı Çünkü
üreme organlarımız o ya da bu şekilde
istesek de istemesek de kendiliğinden
çalışmaya devam ediyor
üreme organlarımız adet oluyoruz falan
devam ediyor ama cinsel organlarımızın
ve cinsel organlarımızın işlevi üzerine
korkularımızın kaygılarımızın toplumsal
bilincimizin
bilinmezliklerimizin o kadar çok yeri
var ki bilmiyoruz ama günün birinde
bizim kullanmamızı bekliyorlar erkek
perspektifinden işler biraz farklı
olabilir
biraz daha şeyler biraz daha rahatlar
cinsellik konusunda Gerçi o tarafta da
çok fazla problem var performans
kaygıları penis boyu ile ilgili kaygılar
ereksiyon sorunları hepsi problemli ama
bugün kadını konuştuğumuz için kadın o
sınıftan bir kız Ergen hiçbir şeyini
bilmeden çıkıyor
fakat günün birinde evleniyor ya da bir
uzun süreli ya da her neyse bir cinsel
birliktelik yaşaması bekleniyor
hayatında duymadığı organlara nasıl
çalışıyor Nasıl bilmiyor Çünkü bakınca
göremiyor falan o organları kullanması
bekleniyor
bu kullanmadan zevk alması bekleniyor
zevk vermesi bekleniyor Nasıl olacak bu
bilmediğimiz organı kullanmaya
çalışıyoruz Bir de zevk almaya
çalışıyoruz Nasıl olacak bu mümkün değil
her şeyi bilmek zorundayım ben bir işli
bir işe gireceksem bir araba
kullanacaksam yüzeceksem bilmek
zorundayım
bedenimizde taşıdığımız hayatımız
boyunca tanışmadığımız organlar günüm
birinde
vakti gelince bizim kullanabileceğimiz
organlar haline gelmiyor ve bizler
korkularımız kaygılarımız sebebiyle
bilinmezliklerimiz sebebiyle cinsel işle
bozukluğu yaşıyoruz kitaplar diyor ki
kadınların %50 Senin cinsel işleri
sorunu var
salondaki kadınların yüzde yani anlamda
%50'si cinsi işle bozukluğu var tabii ki
olacak çünkü organlarını tanımıyor
fizyolojisini bilmiyor anatomisini
bilmiyor Nasıl kullanılacağını bilmiyor
Tabii ki de bir cinsiyetle bozukluğu
olacak
en büyük cinsel organımız neresi
Evet
İzmir değil ve herkes Çok tatlı çünkü
ben bunu her danışanıma soruyorum
penisyen vajina diyen daha çok beyin
dediğiniz için çok teşekkür ederim En
büyük cinsel organımız Kulaklarımız
arasındadır yani beynimizdir Fakat
beyniniz o kadar kirli ki konu cinsellik
olunca
Çünkü biz cinselliği hiç olmaması
gereken şekilde öğreniyoruz okulda
anlatmıyorlar evde anlatmıyorlar orada
anlatmıyorlar doğru bir şey öğrenmiyoruz
nereden öğreniyoruz
eşten dosttan sağdan soldan pornodan çok
yanlış bir yoldur bakın [__] izlenir
izlenmez ayrı bir mevzu cinsel eğitimin
bir parçası olamayacak bir yoldur [__]
öğrenmek
korku dolu hikayelerden öğreniyoruz
onun cinselliği ilk gecesi ağrılı geçmiş
bunun ki böyle geçmiş
böyle öğreniyoruz cinsellik korku dolu
kanamalı hikayelerden öğreniyoruz
Böyle bizim gibi topraklarda acaba
aksini düşünen var mı böyle öğreniyoruz
benim buna İtirazım Var Benim şu anda
yaşanan cinselliğe İtirazım Var ve
üzgünüm Beyler penis odaklı yaşanan
cinselliğe İtirazım Var kadının
cinselliğini Ve hazlarını ikinci plana
atan kadının orgazmı olmasa da olur
zaten çok zor denilen cinselliğe
İtirazım Var Çünkü kadın orgazmı sizin
peniste yaşadığınız orgazm kadar mümkün
fakat biz bunu bilmiyoruz öğrenmedik
öğrenmediğimiz bir şey kullanamayız
problemimiz bu insanlar neden cinsellik
Yaşar üreme odaklı cinsellik işin bir
boyutu sadece Tabii ki üreyelim ne kadar
güzel nefsimiz devam etsin fakat
insanlar zevk almak ve zevk vermek için
de cinsellik yaşarlar
ama sanki bu bizim gibi topraklarda
erkeğin zevk aldığı kadının da Pasif bir
şekilde içinde yer aldığı bir eylemler
bütünü olarak görünüyor
ve kadın öyle duran bir canlı orada
erkek aktif bir eylemde bulunuyor
kadında pasif duruyor Hayır
öyle bir şey yok Çünkü bunu aşmadığımız
sürece bunu revize etmediğimiz sürece
mutlu bir kadın olmamız ve mutlu bir
ilişkiye sahip olmamız da mümkün değil
Önce kadının cinselliğini yeniden
tanımlamamız gerekiyor kadının orgazmını
kadının cinsel haklarını kadının
orgazmik haklarını ve buna kapasitesi
olduğunu yeniden tanımlamamız gerekiyor
şimdi bu penis
böyle bakınca görülüyor falan aynada
değil mi yani bakıyoruz görüyoruz filan
da tam olarak böyle yapmış
anatomi kitaplarında yıllar boyu penisi
en boy sağ sol ön arka her yerden
çizmişler
kadının cinsel anatomisi ise sadece dış
dudak dediğimiz ki adı vulvadır vajina
değildir onu da söyleyeyim
Urfa'dan dışarıdan görülen iki tane
[__] arasında işte öyle bir
böyle bir organ olarak çizmişler
Sonraları demişler ki burada bir şey var
bezelye gibi Acaba ne bu oraya koymuşlar
demişler ki buna da kriteris olsun
oraya koymuşlar yıllarca anatomi
kitapların hepsinde kritoris bir bezelye
tanesi olarak gösterildi
bezelye tanesi fakat biz bugün biliyoruz
ki
fakat kriterolis ile ilgili
farkındalığımız Onun bir kompleks
halinde içeriye doğru uzanan bir yapı
olduğunu
1998 yılında öğrendik o gün aya basalı
29 yıl olmuştu
Biz Ay'a gitmiştik 29 yıl sonra klit
öğrendik
Peki kritos ve penisin aynı şey olduğunu
söylesem size
klitor ise penis gelsin o zaman
sevgili dinleyiciler
Burası hepinizin bildiği penis bilmeyen
ve tanımayan yoktur diye düşünüyorum çok
ünlü bir organ çünkü
Burası da kayıt
sonrası Şuradaki Pointer yok herhalde
oradaki bezelye var ya Tepedeki
erkekteki penisin başkasına dediğimiz
glass'in karşılık kadar Bildik
1998 yılına kadar
1998 yılında Amerikalı bir Pardon
Avusturyalı bir ürolog Profesör dediki
böyle bir şeymiş aslında
ilk 6 hafta anne karnındaki ilk 6 hafta
bazı kaynaklara göre dişi ben burayı
kabul ediyorum ama bazı kaynaklara göre
unisex olduğumuzu söylesem size
anne karnındaki ilk 6 hafta bir
Jinekolog olarak söylüyorum o bir buçuk
santimlik bir
ölçüme sahipken
içerde primordial fallus dediğimiz bir
yapı var
primordialatiği Taşıyan embriyo Eğer y
kromozomuna sahipse
testesteron senteziyle birlikte en ünlü
organa çevriliyor
ama ortamda test testleri o yoksa Kriter
olarak kalıyor
birebir aynı yapıdan bahsediyoruz
kriterolste erekti oluyor Aynı penis
gibi
büyüyor aynı penis gibi
ama biz bir şey öğrendik sevgilisi
buradan alalım vajinal orgaz
vajina orgazm diye bir şey yok
arkadaşlar çok üzgünüm yok
orgazmların hepsi klitoraldir
tenisisse orgazm olan erkeklere karşı
kritorisli orgazm olan kadınlar vardır
ne kadar güzel değil mi Ortada hiçbir
şey yok ama biz bir şeyler içimize girip
çıktıkça orgazm olacağımızı sandık
olamadık üzüldük
karşıdakinin suçladık kendimizi eksik
gördük orgaz taklidi yaptık kadınların
%80 hayatı boyunca bir kere yapmıştır
doğrusunu çığlık atmak olduğunu sandık
Bir de çığlık attık filan
öyle bir şey yok
Ben [__] dünyanın en ünlü [__]
oyuncuları ile röportaj yaptım hepsi
numara yapıyor
yanlış söyleyeyim yani yaptım birebir
klitoris uyarılmıyorsa geriye kalan her
şey hikayedir
[Müzik]
kendi dönemi için 1900'lü yılların
başından bahsediyoruz radyoloji yok emar
yok O yok bu yok falan filan
adam bir teori koydu kendi içinde çok
haklıydı ama şu an
2022'deyiz ve biliyoruz ki
vajinanın kendisinde orgazmik bir alan
yoktur
vajinanızda bakın Bu cümleler çok tek
tek önemli vajinanızın kendisiyle orgazm
olamazsınız vajina bir üreme yoludur
adet kanının atıldığı bebeğin çıktığı
penisin girdi
bir kadının orgazm olabilmesi için
o bezelyenin klitoralinin baş kısmının
uyarılması ya da klin İçerdeki kısmın
uyarılması gerekir
bu klin İçerdeki kızım kısmı vajinanın
girişini sardığı için işte kendisi girip
çıkarken oraya uyardığı için içeride
penis varken orgazm olduğumuz için
biz buna vajinal orgazmı demişiz ama
Freud yanılmıştı bunun adı vajinal
orgazm değildi bu da klit öyle
orgazmıydı
bu yapının adı artık klitoral kompleks
Eğer erkekler penisleri ile orgazm
oluyorlarsa
embriyolojiden anlattım size kadınlarda
kriterologlar O yüzden size
hissettirilen
Sen niye böyle orgazm olamıyorsun
cümlelerin artık bir kenara bırakıyoruz
klitoris uyarısı yok sol gazlama
olamazsınız
bunun salondaki her birey için
söylüyorum partnerlerinizde sevgili
Beyler bunu yaşatmayın Bunu
uyarmadığınız hiçbir ilişkide
partnerinizi orgazm olamayacak en iyi
ihtimalle taklit yapacak Siz de yaptınız
mı iyi bir şey olduğunu düşünüp öyle
devam edeceksiniz
değil mi yani Bir de böyle bir şey var
taklidin böyle bir tarafı da var
taklit yaparsanız sevgilim üzülmesin
eşim üzülmesin diye O yaptığı davranışa
devam edecek bir dakika ben bir şey
öğrendim bu uyarılmadan orgazm
olamıyormuşum bunu öğrendim
Çünkü yapılmış çalışmalar Türkiye
çalışmaları değil bunlar Bazıları bana
diyor ki Siz Türkiye'de çalış Hayır
dünya verileri kadınların penis vajina
birlikteliğinde kadınların örttüğü
üçünün zaten orgazm olamadığını söylüyor
ama bakarsak Biz herkes çok mutlu orgazm
oluyor her yeri olamıyorlar çünkü hepsi
bizim kliniklerde onu da söyleyeyim
cesurlar geliyor Cesur olmayanlar
gelmiyor ya da bunu bir sorun olarak
görmüyorlar
Karar sizin Tabii ki sorun olarak görüp
görmemek Herkesin kendi cinselliği
gidip de bizim cinselliğimizde kadın
cinsel eşitsizliği konuşmak istiyorum
şimdi ama biz ne oluyor bu bir
cinsellikte değil mi yani penis vajinaya
girene kadar bir kızdan
penis vajinaya girdikten sonra bir
kadından bahsediyoruz toplum içinizdeki
içindeki yeriniz çok üzgünüm Bu benim
ifadem değil ama bir penisin girmesiyle
ölçülüyor uğruna kadınlar öldürülüyor
namus cinayetleri filan
namus ve bekaret kavramı bacaklarımızın
arasında zaten değildir ya bunu çok net
bir kanıtlayalım
Şimdi biz her şeyi penis sodayla
görüyoruz
cinselliği bir şeylerin bir şeylerin
içine girdiği zaman cinsellik sayıyoruz
geri kalan her şey ön sevişme diyoruz
sevişme ama işte bu hepsi penis vajinaya
girsin diye değil mi Ben de hazırlanayım
Sen de hazırlan
ön sevişme dediğim şey aperatif
ama ana yemek penis vajina birlikte
tenis vajinaya girdi diye kadınlar
orgazm olamaz penis vajina ilişkisi
erkeklerin orgazm yoludur kadınların
orgazm yolu
kritorison'un ayrılmasıdır bunun nasıl
başardığınızın da bir önemi yoktur
penisin uyarmanın nasıl bir önemi yoksa
klitorisinde uyarılması Nasıl
uyarıyorsanız uyarın ama adı ön sevişme
değil başka repertuarlar var konumuz
dışı
şimdi bitireceğiz evet yavaş yavaş
öğrenilmemiş cinsellik bizi haz vermez
korkularla dolu cinsellik bizi orgazma
götürmez
korkuyoruz bir şey yaşamaya korkuyoruz
Başımıza geleceklerden korkuyoruz iyi
kız olamamaktan korkuyoruz böyle orgazm
olamayız Eğer kadın orgazmı diye bir
kavram varsa bu arada
kitabımın Adı Kadın orgazma
aynı Erkekler nasıl orgazm oluyorsa ve
biz onlara penis orada mı demiyorsak
Buna bir erkek orgazm olarak bakıyorsak
kadının orgazmada kadın orgazmadır artık
vajinal orgazm ve klitörle orgazmı
ayırmıyoruz orgazm olduğunu da lütfen
nasıl oluyorsanız olun ve bunu bir
mağduriyet Ben öyle oldum O şöyle
oluyormuş değil Sen bir biriciksin Sen
özel bir bedensin herkesin orgazmı
kendine mutlu ol da yeter bizim için
[Alkış]
şunu söyleyeyim Her Birinizin sevgili
kadınlar erkekleri şu an şöyle bir
ayırdım çünkü onları penisi var Onu
biliyoruz onu gördük
hepinizin var
Ben biliyorum Jinekolog olarak biliyorum
ve Her biriniz kriterole lazlarla
tanışırsanız sen sen sen sen salondaki
tüm kendini kadın bedeniyle Doğanlar
hepinizi orgazm olabilirsiniz sadece
beklentilerimizi farklılaştıralım bunu
öğrenmeye çalışalım çalışalım birazcık
beklemeyelim çalışalım
çünkü orgaz
M verilen bir şey değildir
orgazm biri bize veremez
çok üzgünüm bir penis bir zor gazım
yapamaz bir klitoris kesinlikle bizi
orgazm yapabilir Bundan emin olun
kadınlar için konuştum penis orgazmı
erkekler oluyor zaten hani woman'dayız
falan ya o yüzden
Evet orgazmınızın sorumluluğu kendinizde
önce kendi bireysel deneyimlerinizi
keşfetmek zorundasınız kendi orgazmınızı
keşfetmek zorundasınız bunun yolu yüksek
sesle söyleyebiliriz mastürbasyondur
yani erkeklerin ergenlikten beri yaptığı
mastürbasyon
önce mastürbasyonla kendi ağızlarınızı
kendi erojen bölgelerinizi keşfetmek
zorundasınız ki onu vakti geldiğinde bir
ötekiyle paylaşabilin
kadının bilmediği yıllarca üzerinde
taşıdığı ama tanışmadığı erkeğin zaten
sahip olmadığı bir organdan Biz başka
türlü nasıl orgazmı çıkarabiliriz önce
biz tanışacağız
yolunu Siz keşfedeceksiniz
çalışacaksınız uğraşacaksınız aynı yüzme
iyi öğrenmek gibi aynı araba kullanmayı
öğrenmek gibi Dolayısıyla
bedeninizi seviyorum
varoluş şeklinizin şöyle bir organınız
var onu zaten çok iyi biliyoruz bunu
bilelim biz bunu bilelim
tanışın onu Sevin varlığına şükredin ve
orgazmınızla tanışın teşekkür ediyorum
bir de
umarım
kadınlıkla barışırsınız bizim böyle bir
sorunumuz var Çünkü bizim böyle bir
sorunumuz var suçluluk günahkarlık namus
Bekarlık duygularını arınıp
en az erkekler kadar Özgür haklara sahip
olabileceğimiz günler diliyorum Her
biriniz için çok teşekkürler
[Alkış]